There are forces at work against women, but
I also think that women can counteract those
forces with just a little bit of changes to
their behavior.
And myself included, could I go back ten
years ago I would have done things a little
bit differently, maybe being more forceful,
asking for more things, not expecting that
they would come to me if I deserved them,
and just putting my neck on the line a little
bit more.
That’s maybe me, that’s maybe my personality.
Things have worked out for me so far, but
there’s a fine line -- what is a personality
thing and what is what you’ve kind of been
taught by society as what is the polite, right
way to do and behave.
My advice for young women today and things
I wish I would have known or done differently
. . . there’s a lot.
But I would start with:
Just be aggressive.
Even if you think you’re being aggressive,
you’re probably not.
And whether that’s, you know, emailing someone
again who hasn’t emailed you back, picking
up the phone and calling them again if they
haven’t called you back, who cares?
Just do it.
If you don’t kind of push, nobody will hear
you.
Ask for things.
Ask for things from your boss.
Ask for things from your people around you.
Ask for raises, ask for promotions, ask for
more responsibility.
Nobody’s necessarily looking out for you
and going to kind of take you and lift you
up.
You have to do it yourself.
Jump on opportunities.
Don’t worry so much about getting everything
on your list done.
I read a fabulous book called Nice Girls Don’t
Get the Corner Office, and it’s sort of
101 things that you can do to change your
behavior, and it’s really—it came out
a long, long time ago.
It was a huge bestseller.
One of the things it said, you know, was that
women are achievers and men are careerists.
So a woman is more likely to sit there all
day, sit at her desk, even if it means having
lunch at her desk, and just make sure she
checks off everything on her to-do list, whereas
a guy is more likely to, like, get up, go
around the office, go see somebody, go have
lunch, come back, and just kind of, you know,
focus more on the bigger picture.
I think there’s a lot of truth to that.